You don't have to attend every argument
you're invited to.
>> Yeah,
>> that's brilliant.
>> Thank you.
>> It is a a mindset of instead of the
default where somebody is engaging an
opinion with you, like we're opinion-
making machines.
>> Something happens in the world, where
does everybody turn to? Social media to
share their opinion to who? their
audience of six people that you know are
on [snorts] their Facebook or something
and they and they go and they flood all
the comments of how much they agree they
disagree and who's attacking who and
who's a snowflake and who's the whatever
and that kind of behavior solves is
nothing and in fact it's very draining.
In fact, if we want to say that's a
symptom of a very bad health, you know,
a lot of the times those kind of people
are are unhealthy, not just physically,
but mentally un unwell. All right? So,
if you want to make sure that you stop
attending every argument you're invited
to, you need to understand that there's
a priority of what's important in your
life. There are people that disagree
with you and there are people who maybe
don't even like you. Most likely if they
don't like you, they're not that
important, you know? Who who do you want
to keep in your life?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Who who do you want to surround
yourself with? And I feel like anytime
somebody gives you an invitation to an
argument, we go, "Oh, yep. Absolutely.
Check." Yes. I will be attending.
>> And that's a that's a one-way ticket to
um bad health.
>> It comes down to emotional awareness,
self-awareness, emotional regulation,
doesn't it? Because
when you are more self-aware and
emotionally regulated,
I think it becomes easier to
not attend every argument. When your
nervous system is in high alert, when
you've been busy with work all day, you
didn't take a lunch break, you're in
sort of that stress mode.
>> Yeah.
>> It's sometimes harder to separate,
>> right? And I think sometimes fear is
also what gets in the way of many things
in our life, but also our ability to
communicate well, right? And I think the
more we're better to emotionally
regulate, the more better able we are to
go, hey, you know what? I don't I don't
want to get involved with that.
>> You know, something I've learned being
online sharing information for about 12
years now is
>> I don't have to have an opinion on
everything. [laughter]
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Or or you can have an opinion and
not share it.
>> Yeah. I certainly don't need to have a
public opinion or anything. Now people
can expect me to.
>> Right.
>> I should be commenting on this event.
Great.
>> No problem.
>> I don't think I should.
>> Right.
>> I don't want to. And ultimately to me
what I what I will and what I won't
communicate on. Right. It's kind of
interesting. What have you learned?
Right. So this is interesting. You were
already an exceptional communicator.
You started sharing things online in
2022. So about 3 years or so, you've had
a lot of experience with comments on
social media. So what
>> what has being on social media and
reading comment sections
taught you about other human beings. You
know, I I'll tell you, I'm blessed with
a wonderful audience. I I can probably
count on one hand truly the amount of
times I've had a a negative troll type
of just nasty comment, which is just
wonderful. And most of the time they're
they're bots, you know, they're not
they're not real. Um, but what I have
seen, of course, because I'm on social
media like you are, I have seen people
leave negative, horrible comments in
YouTube, Tik Tok, Instagram, you you
name it, where the quick little clapback
that's ugly, maybe on somebody's
weight, appearance, looks, what they
said, and it gets a lot of likes. like a
crazy yeah amount of likes because
there's this anonymity of being behind
the keyboard and you almost in some
sense get rewarded for it. When somebody
is liking your comment, what are you
encouraged to do? Say more ugly things
>> to get more like and appreciation and uh
that that that dopamine hit of you're
you're doing something well. So what I
have seen is that people in comments can
be I've seen it both ways. I've seen the
negative side of it and it's
detrimental. I've also seen the very
positive side of people can create a
community in the comments. And you take
something like Tik Tok for example.
Sometimes the comments are more
entertaining than the actual content
itself. People immediately what they
would say run to the comments
>> because there's so much interaction or
things that are funny. People are
hilarious.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, I' one thing about social media
is that there's so many talented people
and so many funny people that you would
never know that, you know, they're total
totally um total introverts, but they're
funny and creative and things you would
never be able to see in the the world
and environment that you're that you're
in. So, I've been blessed with being
able to see the positive. I've been
blessed with being able to see the the
negative of it in in social media. And I
I find I certainly a product of it. I
wouldn't be here with you today had
people not resonated with the the
content that I make.
>> I would bet that one of the reasons you
don't get many negative comments is
because of your energy.
>> People respond to energy. They they do.
You know, we all respond to energy and
the vibe of the people around us. And so
if you're putting out content with a
really warm,
compassionate, grounded energy with a
real desire to help people,
>> right,
>> it's just not going to lead to that many
people, you know, trying to meet that
energy with division and criticism. Do
you know what I mean? Whereas some
people, their whole brand is about
>> calling out or this is what's toxic or
whatever it might be, whatever it is. So
of course that energy is going to
attract more energy like that
>> which is super interesting. I mean I
also r very rarely get negative
comments. Um but I've always had a rule
actually an internal rule with myself
which is which maybe I didn't follow in
the early days of being you know online
sharing information but I've leared
through the process which is
>> it comes back to some of your teachings
in this book right which is
>> if I'm not feeling calm
>> do not respond to a comment.
>> Yeah that's so true.
>> You know don't do it. It's never going
to come go well you know only respond.
So sometimes it's like I I think
actually that's worthy of a response.
Like I I feel that would be good to
interact with that. But only do it when
you're feeling calm. And calm doesn't
just mean my internal. It also means
what's going on in my life.
>> Yes.
>> Right. It's more important that I'm
going to spend quality time with my
children or my wife or going around to
see my mom.
>> Yes.
>> Actually, you know what? That is more
important
>> than a random comment on my Instagram
page.
>> Absolutely. And probably the truth is
that's one comment out of 200. Yeah. You
know what I mean? And so you have you
might have 199 wonderful comments and we
see that one and we kind of go
>> and we want to comment right there and
you know it does nothing. I get
questions. I know you get questions of
people when I post I get negative
comments and or you know how do you
handle it? And I go do you have to what
do you what I mean the algorithm doesn't
care if it's happy or sad. It's a
comment at the same time. Do you know
this person? Are you going to actually
sit down and spend time with this
person? What's going on in your life?
>> I I sort of in in my in my last book, uh
Jefferson, Make Change at Last, there's
a chapter called Take Less Offense.
Okay. I think you'd really enjoy it
actually. And um
in that chapter, I make the case that
offense is something we choose to do,
right? Nothing is inherently offensive
because if it was, we'd all find the
same thing offensive.
>> Yeah. I love that. The fact that we
don't means it's not the comment or the
thing that was causing the offense. It
was something within us that was being
activated. Right. Right. I'm not
excusing poor behavior here. Sure. I'm
just saying that nothing is inherently
offensive. We're choosing to take
offense.
>> Right. And I sort of also make the case
in that chapter
>> that on some level
taking offense is actually or could be
argued to be a little bit arrogant. And
and and the reason I say that is because
if you think about it rationally,
there's 8 billion people on the planet,
right? Is it reasonable to believe that
every other human being on this planet
is going to have the same view and
perspective on the world as I do? No.
Right? It's not reasonable at all.
Clearly, some people in the world are
going to see the world differently from
me. They're going to have different
ethics, different religion, uh different
way of being brought up, uh different
levels of trauma, whatever it might be.
They're going to see the world
differently. So, they may actually
disagree with me on certain things. They
may see things completely differently.
It doesn't mean that they're wrong and
I'm right or I'm right and they're
wrong. Just means they see it
differently.
>> Yes.
>> You choose to take offense to certain
things. And
>> I I'm of the mindset of anytime
you just hear change, you hear about
change, it makes you uncomfortable. you
hear about change in the world or
somebody having a different political
view than you, that's change. You're
hearing that makes you go, I don't like
that. So, whenever you find and hear
that change that's being communicated to
you and it makes you uncomfortable, that
creates a lot of that fear because we
like what is safe, we like what is
known. you. Let's say I want to change
your mind about something and you have
this political view. Let's say it's a
religious view for example and I say
that as something that's typically very
crystallizing as part of somebody's
identity. Well, if I just expect in one
conversation I'm going to entirely
disprove everything that you've ever
believed, problems are going to happen
because what's most likely is I'm not
just saying you're wrong. I'm saying
your parents are wrong. I'm saying your
grandmother's wrong. I'm saying that
thing that you learned when you were a
kid and you've known your entire life is
all wrong. And people will
will do anything far past the point of
just deciding not to listen to you in
order to preserve what they know.
>> And it is so easy for people. That's why
a lot of times in a political climate,
they're okay with one candidate doing
it. They're not okay with another
candidate doing it. They're okay if it's
the side I am comfortable with. I'm not
good with if it's a side I don't agree
with. Why? Because we feel comfortable
with what we know because it's comes
down from the people that put their
value in us. And we will defend the
people in our lives that have
contributed to that view. So in other
words, you can say I'm wrong. Yeah. But
if you're saying my dad's wrong, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, wait, wait, wait,
wait. Don't you don't get to say my
dad's wrong. I I'm the one. And so we
get defensive on behalf of the people
that help shape our identity. And so we
will do anything to the point of just
refusing to listen even to logic, even
to evidence, even somebody presents you
with evidence of saying something of why
your position is wrong on it. We will
boldface just disagree with it in order
to protect the values that we've been
raised with.
>> Yeah, it's a great point. I mean
obviously you are an American citizen
and you know American politics is
uh very interesting these days.
>> That's a great word. Yeah, let's keep it
to that word. Yeah,
>> it's very interesting. And
I think 12 months ago the statistic that
I came across uh was that one in six
US adults are not talking to another
family member because of a difference of
opinion.
>> Yeah. over politics, which I found
utterly remarkable. Right.
>> Right. And really just speaks to what
you just said. Right. Yes.
>> And I guess
>> that in many ways highlights why a book
like yours is so important. Right.
Because it should be possible
for two people with completely different
religions or completely different
political beliefs within the same
family. It should be possible to have a
conversation with them. Yes. and still
love them and still respect them. You
know, of course, people will argue that
there are extremes. There are certain
things that people can't get over. Okay.
But as a general principle, you should
be able to get on with people who see
the world differently than you do.
>> Yes.
>> Which is something you don't see online
much. But if I think about even my best
mates from university, like there's four
or five of us, and you know, we're we'd
be there for each other. You know, we
could rely on each other for anything. M
>> doesn't mean we all see the world the
same way.
>> We we you know we have differences of
opinions of things. We're still best
mates
>> but it seems as though the world at
least online
>> well I say online it's getting more
divided but that statistic would suggest
that actually offline as well it's
getting more divided as well.
>> Yeah I definitely believe so because
we're not allowing real conversation. We
we expect that we can solve all issues
in one conversation. In fact, I'll go
even more. We feel like we can solve
everything and change someone's mind by
saying one sentence. And we just think
because I said it, well, then they have
to wholeheartedly swallow it, agree with
it, take it, and say, "I'm the most
amazing genius they've ever heard. Yes,
of course you're right." And that's just
never going to that's never going to
happen. And instead, you have to see
that if you want to change someone's
mind,
you better be ready to have
multiple conversations. I'm talking
conversations over years, things that
you're going to have to invest in asking
questions and finding out why someone
believes what they do. When you actually
take the time rather than fighting
fighting the opinion they have, you take
the time to find out why they have it.
>> Exactly. and how they learned it and
where they picked it up and when they
learned it. All of that information is
going to give you way more knowledge and
realize it's not the symptom, it's the
cause.
>> Yeah. Is it even possible to change
someone's mind? It's like maybe the goal
is never to change someone's mind. Maybe
the goal should be to learn.
>> Yeah. I like Well, I would reframe that
the Yes, you can change one someone's
mind, but what you said is right. You
have to change the goal. Too often we
put the we put a bar on conversations of
and that bar is they have to admit I'm
right. They have to say they're wrong.
>> That is rarely if ever going to happen.
I can't get my child to say that. I
think I'm going to have someone who's a
grown adult say that who's had a year or
or years a whole life of experiences.
Yeah. And I think just because I uttered
sound into the ear, they're
automatically just going to go the
scales fall from my eyes. How wrong I
am. That's not going to happen, right?
And so you you can absolutely change
someone's mind, but one, you have to
live it. You can't just say it and there
be misalignment in how you're you're
living.
>> Two, yes, evidence helps, but sometimes
when you're trying to push your opinion,
that makes me come closer more. So, for
example,
the more I tell you you're wrong, the
more convinced you're going to be that
you're right.
>> Yeah.
>> You're you're going to protect you're
going to protect what you know because
this is the one thing you feel like you
do know that you're sure about. Why?
Because your dad told you about it when
you were five, you know. So, you will
wrap yourself onto that that memory. So,
can you change someone's mind? Yes, 100%
you you can. But you cannot do it when
you raise the bar as I'm right, you're
wrong. Instead, I'm telling you to lower
the bar. That's what the book does. It
tells you to lower the bar. Instead of
saying I need to prove that I'm right,
my goal is to understand where you're
coming from. My goal is to ask more
questions than I say things. My goal is
to am I showing appreciation for the
time that we're spending in this
conversation. When you set the bar
really low of just making sure you feel
understood and they feel understood and
they feel acknowledged, set a bar of how
can I show that I acknowledge them in
this conversation.
>> That's going to lead to more of what you
want rather than setting that bar that's
and that you can never meet.
>> Yeah. Some of what you just said there
speaks to one of the other life lessons
in the book which is never win an
argument.
>> Yeah.
>> What does that mean? Whenever you set
out to win an argument, you will lose
the relationship over time. If I were to
say, do you know anybody in your life
who always has to be right? They always
have to have the final say. They always
have to have the last word. Those kind
of people are not someone anybody wants
to be around. It's typically an audience
of one. And the more you try to win and
prove, you lower the quality and
connection of that relationship. What
you've really won is their contempt.
Let's say you and I are in an argument.
Rather than me trying to understand you,
I have to win. Win often sounds like I'm
the last one to talk. That's what we
typically have in conversations. The one
who says something last
>> is the one who somehow wins. Maybe you
said something really ugly because you
and I have been personal friends for
forever. And I know that one button that
I can say that speaks right to your
insecurity and all of a sudden you shut
down. Does that mean I win? Probably
not. But that's the feeling. Or if you
and I are in a conflict of opinion and
I'm the one that says, "No, I have to be
right." And you go, "You know what?
Fine. You're right. You're right. Is
that really winning?" Over time, they're
going to feel contempt for you. What you
really want is to be the first to
apologize. I mean, that's that's kind of
the procedure of of arguments. The
person who said the worst thing last is
typically the one who has to apologize
first. What I like to teach is instead
of trying to win the argument, you look
to unravel them. You find the knots in
the conversation and get really quick
and really proficient at loosening them.
>> Why do you think so many people take
things personally when they're having a
conversation?
Our
default is to make things about me, make
things about I, not so much you.
And it's just a shift of perspective
that we make everything
>> everything about about us. Like as me,
as an um a young associate at the law
firm, us associates um would complain
about the partners. We go the partners
don't care. Partners don't listen to us.
The partner, all they do is think about
themselves.
When I made partner, I got a within
probably five minutes, I got an email
and I thought these associates,
all they do is care about themselves.
You know, it's very us versus them
mentality. When you're the employee, you
hate the management. When you're the
management, you hate the employee. You
always find a way to make it about you.
It's it's our default. It's why we take
things personally. It's why when you if
I were to text you okay, you're not
going to be look at that. Look how nice
Jefferson is. He said okay in the
happiest way possible. Instead, you're
going to go okay. What kind of okay is
that? Is like a Is that a okay? Okay. Or
is that like a okay? Like what? We we
find ways of reading the negative in
text and email, any transactional
correspondence like that. If you enjoyed
that clip and want to see the rest of
the conversation, you can click right
here. Or if you want to see the latest
episode of the Jefferson Fisher podcast,
click right here and I'll meet you